اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل ثلاثه من
جنوده واصابه ضابط بنيران شرطي مصري قتل
كذلك على الحدود مع مصر وان تحقيقا مشتركا
بدا بشان الحادثه التي وصفتها تل ابيب
بالاستثنائيه لكنها قالت انها لن تؤثر على
التعاون الامني مع القاهره اما الجيش
المصري فاكد ان الجنود الاسرائيليين قتلوا
في تبادل اطلاق النار بين عنصر امن مصري
ومهربي مخدرات
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي الملابسات التي
احاطت بمقتل الجنود الاسرائيليين الثلاثه
على الحدود مع مصر وكيف نفهم تضارب
الروايات الاسرائيليه بشانك وما مغزى
التباين في تفسير الواقعه بين حديث الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن عدم معرفه الجانب المصري
بنوايا الجندي الذي اطلق النار على الجنود
وحديث الجيش المصري عن تبادل اطلاق النار
في مطارده مرتبطه بالمخدرات منعكاسات هذه
العمليه على الداخل الاسرائيلي وكيف
ستتعامل حكومه نتنياهو مع تبعاتها داخليا
وامنيا في سياق التعاون مع مصر في منطقه
يسميها الجيش الاسرائيلي الخاصره حدوديه
الرخوه
[موسيقى]
بعد اكثر من روايه قدمها بشان الحادثه اكد
الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل ثلاثه من جنوده
برصاص شرطي مصري في حادثين منفصلين قتل في
اولهما جنديين اسرائيليين فجرا عند معبر
العوجه على الحدود مع مصر قبل ان يتبادل
اطلاق النار بعد ساعات من ذلك مع قوه
اسرائيليه ما ادى لمقتله ومقتل جنديا
اسرائيلي اخر واصابه ضابط الحادث الذي قال
قائد المنطقه الجنوبيه في الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه اعتبر ارهابيا منذ لحظه
اكتشاف شقه الاول يخضع الان لما سماه
تحقيقا معمقا بالتعاون مع الجانب المصري
الذي تقول تل ابيب انه بعث رسائل تؤكد انه
لم يكن يعلم نوايا الشرطي منفذ الهجوم
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي قال في رساله
لوزراء حكومته ان حادثه مقتل الجنود
استثنائيه لكنه اضاف انها لن تؤثر على
التعاون الامني مع مصر وبشار روايه الجيش
المصري لما حدث اكد ان عنصر امن اخترق
الحدود اثناء مطاردته مهربي مخدرات ما ادى
الى تبادل اطلاق نار قتل فيه ثلاثه
اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا في بدايه هذه
الحلقه من تل ابيب امير اورينا المحلل
السياسي والعسكري المختص في شؤون الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي سيد
هذا الحادث مقتل الاسرائيلي اكتشف بعد
ساعات من حدوثه لماذا ذهب الاسرائيليون
مباشره لوصفه بانه حادث ارهابي
ما حدث في الليل هو ان كما هو الحال دائما
مخرب مهرب المخدرات من صحراء السيناء
والتي هي ارض مصريه تابعه للسياده المصريه
حاولوا العبور الى صحراء النقب والتي هي
صحراء اخرى في اسرائيل الكتيبه
الاسرائيليه التابعه للجيش الاسرائيلي
المنتشره هناك استطاعت التصدي
للمهربين لكن في الوقت نفسه وفي نقطه
مراقبه اخرى
جنديان احدهما ذكر والاخرى انثى تعرضا
لهجوم من شخص ما قتلهما لكننا لا نعرف ما
هي الدوافع وبعد ساعات وبعد الكشف عن ذلك
من جانب الوحده المعنيه
الوحده بالبحث عن الفاعل وعندما عثروا على
الفاعل داخل اسرائيل فتح النار على الجنود
وقتل جنديا ثالثا وادى الحادث الى مقتله
هو ايضا الامر ما زال قيد التحقيق من قبل
الجانبين
ووزير الدفاع جالنت اتصل
بالفريق احمد زكي نظيره المصري
والطرفان يتعاونان نعم هناك تباينات في
الروايه لكن هذا امر طبيعي للغايه وواضح
انه لا احد لديه اي دوافع
للتصعيد في هذا الحادث المنعزل ليصبح شيئا
اكبر مما هو هل سيؤثر على هذه المنطقه
التي يصفها الاسرائيليون بانها منطقه رخوه
في الحدود في
حدودها مع مصر وتعتبر من بين الاكثر امنا
خاصه مع وجود هذه الحكومه التي توصف
بالمتشدده
والمتطرفه نتيجه هذا الحادث
هذا لا علاقه له بطبيعه سياسه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه اسرائيل لديها ما يكفي من
المشكلات الداخليه ونحن نتحدث الان وعلى
مر خمسه اشهر على التوالي هناك مظاهرات
داخل اسرائيل لكن هذا لا علاقه له بالحدود
الجنوبيه او العكس ما يحدث هو ان كل قوه
عسكريه تكون لها اولويات ومهم ولان هذه
المنطقه مثل الحدود مع الاردن هي من
الاماكن الاكثر امنا لهذا السبب لا تنشر
فيها افضل القوات هم فقط حرس حدود القوات
حرس حدود من كلا الجانبين ولم يتوقع احد
حدوث حادث مثل هذا ولم تكن هناك معلومات
استخباريه حتى يتمكن اي طرف من ارسال
التعزيزات او يتحذر
طوارئ قد تحصل هذه حوادث تتكرر حدثت اليوم
في مصر حدثت من قبل في الاردن كيف يتعامل
معها الاسرائيليون ما هي تاثيراتها
وتداعياتها
كما تعلمون حتى قبل حرب الايام السته في
العام
1967 عندما كانت القدس مدينه منقسمه بين
الفينه والاخرى كان جندي اردني مع فجاه
يفتح النار على المدنيين في الجانب
الاسرائيلي
والسلطات الاردنيه كانت تقول انه اصيب بمس
من الجنود لسبب ما فقط
المختلون عقليا هم موجودين في الجانب
العربي ولا يوجد اسرائيلي يصيبه مس من
الجنود من الجنود ليطلق النار على الطرف
الاخر لكن مع ذلك الامور ستهدا لان هناك
مصالح حيويه في التعاون الامني بين هذه
البلدان الثلاثه مصر والاردن واسرائيل
وللاسف
اسرائيل ان تدفن ثلاثه من شبانها لكن لن
يكون الامر اي التداعيات امير اورينت
المحرر السياسي والعسكري الخبير في شؤون
الامن القومي والسياسه الخارجيه
الاسرائيليه شكرا لك نستكمل نقاش مع
ضيفينا من القاهره السفير حسين هريدي
مساعد وزير الخارجيه المصري الاسبق ومن
رام الله الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين
العام للمبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه اهلا وسهلا بكم سعاده السفير
الهريدي ابدا معك كيف نفهم رغم وجود تعاون
وتحقيق مشترك بين الجانبين المصري
والاسرائيلي في هذه الحادثه كيف نفهم
تباين وربما تناقض الروايتين المصريه
والاسرائيليه بشان ما حدث
بدايه
علميه
في المبدا معترف به معمول به بين كل الدول
العالم ما فيش امن
ثانيا
عند الحدود خصوصا الحدود اللي لها طبيعه
صحراويه
ممكن حوادث من هذا القديم
مثلما شاهدنا شاهدت سينا فجر اليوم ممكن
انها تقع من ان لاخر بالنسبه لتبان
الروايات الروايات الروايه الاسرائيليه
نفسها السد الاسرائيلي نفسه في حضرتك
حاجات غير مقنعه
ومحتاجه لتدقيق ولذلك الجانب المصري بيقوم
بدراسه الوضع
وطبعا في اختلاف بين الروايه
الرسميه الاسرائيليه وما صرح به المتحدث
العسكري المصري
ننتظر نتائج التحقيقات الاجهزه
المصريه لكن
يعني بصفه عامه مشاعر انه الجانب
الاسرائيلي بيكبر وبيضخم من الحادث
يعني
واتصال تليفونى بين وزير الدفاع يعني
الاسرائيلي ووزير الدفاع المصري حوالين
مثل هذا الامر يعني عمليه يعني يعني كبيره
بعض الشيء يعني يعني
الجانب الاسرائيلي صعد الموضوع بشكل لا
يتناسب حضرتك مع
الو
قائع
معنا عنها منذ
اطلاق النار اللي بيلفت النظر اللي بيلفت
نظري انا
يعني خبره سابقه في الجيش في الروايه في
الروايه الاسرائيليه ان هم بيقولوا ان هم
بعد
ساعات
بعد بضع ساعات
عشره على من اطلق النار
طب انتم يعني كيف عرفتوا ان هو اللي اطلق
النار هل عملته مظاهرات بين الرصاص اللي
كان هو سلاح اللي كان بيحمله والعيار
بتاعه
والرصاص اللي قتل الجنود بتاعكم يعني انا
شايف حضرتك انه السرد الاسرائيلي محتاج
لتدقيق وتمحيص ولا احنا لا ينبغي ان ناخذه
على علاج طيب دكتور مصطفى
برايك ايا ما كان ما كانت الروايه
الاسرائيليه والروايه المصريه ايضا مختلفه
عن هذه الروايه ما تاثير ما حدث في الصوره
الكبيره
اولا في موضوع الروايات طبعا اسرائيل
مصابه بحاله يعني في حاله انفجار شديد
لسببين السبب الاول انه في فشل امني
اسرائيلي صارخ وواضح كالشمس يعني عندما
يقتل منهم ثلاثه جنود اثنان ومن ثم ثالث
دون ان يعرفوا ما الذي يجري فهذا يدل على
فشل امن كبير النقطه الثانيه كما ذكرنا في
اكثر من مره هم حسسون جدا للخسائر البشريه
لا يحتمل حدوث خسائر هذا مجتمع اصبح مرفه
لا يطيق حدوث خسائر وبالتالي يتفاعل بشكل
انفعالي كامل مع اي حاله من هذا النوع بس
الشيء الاهم
هذا الشاب المصري الباسل يعني الشرطي اما
انه دافع عن نفسه ثم ثم استشهد او لان
الاسرائيليين اطلقوا عليه الرصاص او انه
قام بعمل وطني مقاوم وفي الحالتين هو في
الواقع شهيد ليس فقط الشعب المصري وانما
الشعب الشعب الفلسطيني والشعب العربي
جمعاء والذي جرى يؤكد فشل نظريه نتنياهو
وفشل النظريه الاسرائيليه بشكل عام التي
كانت تراهن على انها وجود اتفاقيات سلام
مع بعض الدول او حتى اتفاقيات تطبيع مع
بعض الحكومات ان ذلك سيعني تطبيع مع
الشعوب هذا لم يحدث ولن يحدث ابدا الشعب
المصري والشعب الاردني لم يطبع مع اسرائيل
ويتعاطف بشكل كامل مع ما يجري في فلسطين
هذه مشاعر لا تستطيع اسرائيل ان توقفها
القضيه الفلسطينيه وما يعانيه الشعب
الفلسطيني في وجدان كل الشعوب العربيه ما
فيها الشعبين الشقيقين في مصر والاردن
وبالتالي كل شيء ممكن ان يحدث ونظريه
نتنياهو انه يستطيع ان يهمش القضيه
الفلسطينيه ويلغيها من الوجود
ويصادر ويهوض ويضم الاراضي الفلسطينيه
بالكامل وتبقى الامور هادئه اسرائيل تملا
لذلك يعني نظريه اثبتت فشلها بشكل كامل في
نقطه اخرى لابد ان اشير لها وهو يعني
مستوى الخسه والعمل المشين الذي قامت به
اسرائيل بنشر صوره هذا الشرطي الشهيد
المصري وهو شبه عار ونشرها في وسائل
الاعلام في عمل يناقض كل القوانين
الانسانيه والقانون الدولي ويمثل بالفعل
خسه غريبه جدا ومرفوضه بكل المعايير
والمقاييس وهي استفزاز لمشاعر الشعب
المصري والشعب العربيه جميعها في نهايه
المطاف المحصل الرئيسيه لكل ذلك انه لا
يمكن لاسرائيل ان تحظى بامن وامان دون ان
وهي تواصل عمليه قمع وقتل والتنكيل بالشعب
الفلسطيني سعاده السفير هريدي هل بالفعل
اذا ينظر الى الامر شعبيا على الاقل في
مصر ان ما حدث هو عمل مقاومه
يرفض كل اتفاقيات السلام التي وقعت مع
الجانب الاسرائيلي بما في ذلك
الاتفاقيه التي وقعت مع مصر في كامب ديفيد
طبعا حضرتك يعني ما حدث اليوم النهارده
ثلاثه
وبعد يومان هتحل علينا ذكرى خمسه
شخصيا انا يعني بربط بين الحدثين على
الاقل من وجهه نظر اسرائي
ليه واشكر ضيفكم كريم من رملنا ان هو لفت
نظري
الى العمل وانا اتفق معه في وصفه من عمل
خسيس ان هم نشروا سوره
الجندي المصري
وحضرتك طبعا معروف حضرتك يعني احنا مش
محتاجين ناكد انه الشعب المصري جميع طوائف
بيعيش يعيش المعاناه اليوميه للشعب
الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه وفي الضفه الغربيه
والشعب المصري حضرتك
يعني
اتفاق السلام اتفاق السلام دوت التزامات
تعاقديه بين دولتين
وهو غير ملزم بها وبالتالي حضرتك منذ عام
79 لغايه النهارده
يعني ما فيش مظاهر خالص
لتطبيع على مستوى
الشعب وعلى مستوى المهن والاتحادات
المهنيه ليس ان ذلك حضرتك باوامر او
بتعليمات لا دي حضرتك نبعه من داخل من
وجدان الشعب المصري وبالتالي بس من ناحيه
اخرى
ما حدث اليوم يعني احنا يعني انا افضل
ننتظر نتائج التحقيق التي
تجريه وتجريه الان
القوات المسلحه المصريه والاجهزه الامنيه
المصريه
بكافه انواع حتى نعرف الحقيقه طيب
لكن بالنسبه بالنسبه لنا هذا الجندي هذا
الجندي كان بيؤدي واجبه
واحنا حضرتك في
التصريحات اللي قابله بها المتحدث العسكري
المصري هو كان بيطارد حضرتك مجموعه من
مهربي المخدرات وطبعا حضرتك اما بيكون في
حاجه زي كده البنود
بتتعقب المهربين مش بتقف عند الحدود اساسا
حضرتك يعني عايز اقول انه يعني حتى الان
ينبغي ان نضع الحادث في الاطار في اطاره
في الاطار حتى
تظهر التحقيقات الدكتور البرغوثي
هذه الحادثه ونتيجتها كيف يمكن ان تؤثر
داخليا على الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه
حكومه بنيامين نتنياه
سيكون لها تاثيرات كبيره بالتاكيد اولا
لانها تظهر فشل هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
فشل نتنياهو حكومته الفاشيه فشل امني اولا
ثانيا كل ما اسس الامنيه الاسرائيليه كانت
منشغله في الايام الاخيره بالحديث عن
مخاطر هجمات في الشمال ومخاطر ايران
ومخاطر حزب الله ومخاطر ما تقوم به
المقاومه الفلسطينيه الباسله في الضفه
الغربيه في جنين ونابلس ولم يتوقعوا على
الاطلاق هذه المفاجاه التي جاءتهم من
الجنوب لذلك هذا طبعا سيكون له تاثير على
مستوى الامني وعلى المستوى السياسي من
ناحيه ثالث الناحيه الاهم ان ما وعد به
نتنياهو برنامج نتنياهو السياسي خطته التي
سار عليها منذ عام 1994 عندما كتب كتابه
مكان تحت الشمس بان من الممكن تحميش
وتصفيه القضيه الفلسطينيه والحصول على امن
كامل ومطلق لا وعلاقات طبيعيه مع كل الدول
المحيطه هذه النظريه فشلت فشلندريعا ولذلك
الانحدار الذي تعيشه حكومه نتنياهو اليوم
على الصعيد الشعبي حتى في داخل اسرائيل
سيتعاظم وهذا الفشل سيضاف الى سلسله الفشل
المتعدده والمتنوعه التي تواجه هذه
الحكومه في نهايه المطاف انا امل طبعا انه
هذا سيرسخ الاعتقاد العميق بانه لا يمكن
لاسرائيل ان تحصل على امن او امان مطلق ما
دامت قضيه الشعب الفلسطيني لم تحل وما دام
حق الشعب الفلسطيني لم يرد اليه وما دام
الشعب الفلسطيني ما زال يعيش تحت الاحتلال
ونظام القبر تايد العنصري على المدى
البعيد كل ما يجري في المنطقه سيؤدي الى
الضغط في الاتجاه الصحيح وهو ان القضيه
الجوهريه هناك قضيه فلسطين وهي قضيه كما
قال ضيفك ايضا من مصر في وجدان كل الشعوب
العربيه في وجدان شعب مصر وفي وجدان الشعب
الاردني
ولا يمكن لاسرائيل ان تنفي ذلك سفير حسين
هريدي وانت لك خبره دبلوماسيه او كما ذكرت
خبره في الجيش هل سيكون هناك لهذه الحادثه
اي تاثير على العلاقات المصريه
الاسرائيليه من ناحيه السياسيه ومن ناحيه
ما يحدث ايضا على الحدود امنيا بين
الجانبين
يعني انا لا اعتقد حضرتك يعني في تصريح
النهارده
لرعاده التدخين والتهويل الاعلامي
الاسرائي
لي يعني الحادث الذي
وقع على الحدود مع اسرائيل انه قال انه ده
حادث وسطه بل وصف اللي استخدمه انه ده
حادث استثنائي وان هو لن يؤثر على
التعاون بين البلدين في المجال
الامن واضح ان ده تراجع اسرائيلي تهدئه
للراي العام الاسرائيلي بعد التهويل
الاعلامي الكبير الذي ليس له اي مبرر من
جانب سواء العسكريين الاسرائيليين او من
جانب الاعلام الاسرائيلي لكن حضرتك
الموضوع احنا بالنسبه لنا الموضوع اكبر من
هذا
الحادس
احنا حضرتك يعني
في
وفد من حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
يا اما وصل الى القاهره او في طريق الوصول
الى القاهره ثم في وجده اخر حضرتك من
حركه حماس بقياده السيد اسماعيل هنيه من
المقرر ان يصل الى القاهره لاجراء محادثات
مع المسؤولين نعم ويستمر
يستمر الدوري المصري في محادثات من هذا
النوع
لا يشكل احد بطبيعه الحال يظل دائما مهما
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا السفير حسين هريدي مساعد
وزير الخارجيه المصري الاسبق من القاهره
واشكر كذلك الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي من رام
الله شكرا جزيلا لكم
الى هناك انتهى هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر شكرا لكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]